le 13 avril dernier l'enlèvement de la
petite fille avait fait la une de tous
les journaux on est toujours sans
nouvelles de la petite mia cette petite
fille de 8 ans kidnappée à la mi-journée
par trois hommes la fillette qui vivait
avec sa grand-mère dans les vosges avait
été enlevée à la demande de sa mère
mais derrière cette organisation se
cacher un homme remy daillet wiseman un
complotiste français installés en
malaisie ancien président du modem en
haute garonne il est connu pour être
l'une des figures majeures de la sphère
complotistes y avait d'ailleurs pris la
parole dans les médias pour s'exprimer
sur la sphère évidemment il s'agit pas
d'un enlèvement
c'est l'état qui commet des enlèvements
c'est pas nous nous nous restituons des
enfants un homme lit en valeur pas est
alors sorti du silence pour accuser remy
daillet wegmann de manipulation sur son
ex femme avec qui séjournent en malaisie
et du pin à pin de ses trois enfants
j'ai pas une photo de mes enfants je ne
sais même pas si ils sont vivants visé
par un mandat d'arrêt international
remy daillet wegmann et sa femme
viennent d'être arrêté en malaisie pour
séjour irrégulier leur visa touristique
étant arrivé à expiration aujourd'hui 10
lyon 21h lance un appel pour retrouver
ses enfants détenus dans des conditions
déplorables et pour tenter d'enfin les
arracher aux mains de ce gourou il est
avec nous ce soir il fera face à jean
christophe bassons larbi avocat de rémy
daillet wegmann merci m merci à vous
deux dates alors lignon et yaël vous
vivez aujourd'hui un cauchemar vous
accusez le gourou d'avoir volé vos
enfants quand votre femme l'a rejoint
pour bien comprendre cette affaire vous
avez juste regarder cette animation
avant d'en parler regardez donc les
lions et leoni ont trois enfants il ya
elle sanary et ilan est en fête
léonie par vire en malaisie avec remy
daillet en apportant ses enfants et vous
deviez les rejoindre plus tard c'est ça
l'histoire tout à fait un
je l'accuse pas d'avoir volé mes enfants
se terre qui en fait le problème c'est
qu'en fait on a cherché des solutions
pour scolariser nos enfants à l'étranger
ma femme est tombée sur le net sur cette
personne et lui a lu a vendu des
solutions pour scolariser les enfants et
donc on en a fait un projet on s'est
rencontré avec sa famille ses sept
enfants qui sont toujours en france pour
partir en malaisie à deux familles pour
sa part millet mutuellement ensuite ma
femme
artix moi je devais rester un mois
supplémentaire en france pour finir un
peu ma femme est partie de vente comme
on dit et il part il elle part avec remy
daillet en malaisie avec donc votre ex
femme et vos trois enfants voilà les 2
mars 2016
il arrive en malaisie et au bout de
trois jours alors que tout allait bien
avec ma femme je sais pas j'ai pas de
nouvelles veux plus me parler sur skype
alors je trouve bon un père de famille
vous savez qu'il ya tout de suite
quelque chose qui se passe au rouge
quand je vois là je me dis mais il se
passe quelque chose d'étrange
bon après j'essaye de contacter monsieur
d'ailleurs par son skype je me fais
envoyer sur les roses alors que
j'entends je l'entends j'entendais mes
enfants je dis mais pas ce moi mes
enfants supplié en fait il y avait bah
il m'a dit il ya eu des noms d'oiseaux
ça d'ailleurs
il a d'ailleurs porté plainte contre moi
j'ai été convoqué par les gendarmes
parce qu'il ya quelques noms d'oiseaux
sur le skate puisque moi j'entendais mes
enfants qui jouaient derrière jeudi
passe moi mes enfants non il est hors de
question je parle à mes enfants
donc ça ça a été j'ai été loyal j'étais
convoqué à la gendarmerie je me suis
expliqué après donc donc j'ai découvert
alors après j'ai appelé sa femme qui m'a
dit météo pas aux comptes est bien le
dernier de pas être au courant que en
fait ben et on n'est plus ensemble
il est parti en malaisie il est hors de
question qu'on aille nous en malaisie
avec les enfants je dis ah bon d'accord
donc là je demande le divorce
voilà donc je dis bah écoute maintenant
il faut que tu ramènes les uns que les
enfants reviennent alors là hors de
question l'aston est suivi qu'en fait si
elle lui on avait des billets en open
oria elle était là-bas y aller tu es là
bah oui il va vite réalisé que quelque
chose ne va pas bah oui c'est sûr qu'est
ce qui se passe
dames 1 j'ai tout de suite vu qu'il
voulait plus qu'on communique avec mon
père moi j'avais déjà 14 ans j'avais
déjà l'esprit clair et j'avais tout de
suite vu l'adultère qu'ils avaient entre
lui et ma mère d'accord mais c'est
incroyable que tu es là bas lui il voit
donc ta mère partir avec un avec un
autre homme
tu vois toi et
et voilà les frères et soeurs et vous
pouvez plus parler à votre père était en
malaisie à l'autre bout à l'autre bout
du monde
qu'est ce qui te passe par la tête à ce
moment la crise ben moi je voulais tout
de suite rentré
ouais donc il veut dit ça comment tu
joues tu l'as tu l'as dit ça ta mère et
ah oui je leur ai dit il le savait que
je voulais rentrer bien sûr et il te
disais quoi bein il me disait que non
pour moi il fallait il voulait après
voulait pas du tout que je rentre que je
rentre à la maison
d'accord pas du tout alors là tu
remarques que ta maman a une relation
avec ce remy daillet comment tu
remarques sarkis qui quand ils ont
commencé à coucher dans la même chambre
ah ouais bah c'est sûr ça y est
explicite et a pu en parler à tu pouvais
plus en parler tu pouvais plus parler à
ton père non du tout aucune aucune
relation moyens tu pouvais même pas
prendre un téléphone essayé de l'appeler
de rien du tout quoi rien impossible
alors tu comprend vite qu'il veut pas
que ton père vous rejoigne
oui sinon malaisie donc là tu dis tu
viens et non un cauchemar c'est ça
comment tu as fait pour revenir alors on
avait pris des billets aller retour et
donc je me suis dis et je me suis servi
du voyage retour pour rentrer en france
justement tu as fait tu t'es tu t'es
sauvé un jour comment ça s'est passé
alors de ce que j'ai compris il ya eu il
ya eu des échanges en outre ma mère et
mon père mais oui sinon c'était en
grande partie ça il vous a maltraité
l'abrité bah oui moi j'ai été maltraité
en malaisie ça m'est déjà arrivé vu que
je savais qu'il y avait un adulte et
entre lui et le maire que j'étais pas
obéissant qui me kim envoie bouler
dehors dans l'escalier de devant la
maison
timo menace qui me frappe établira
disait rien non non non je pourrais
c'est tellement simple à utiliser
c'est ça elle était complètement sous
son emprise c'était c'est quelqu'un de
vraiment manipulable ma mère et il est
lui c'est un bon manipulateur pour la
coupe alors n'ayez pas scolarisés là bas
non létaux faisait pas toute la journée
moi j'étais dehors je passe le moins de
temps possible avec ma mère ge avec ma
mère et mes façons je rentrais
uniquement à midi pour m'assurer que mes
frères et soeurs avait à manger
il paraît que vous n'aviez même pas à
manger parfois oui c'est ça parfois même
rémy ollier et mamère partait au
restaurant ils nous laissaient il
comptait sur le fait que je rentre à la
maison pour faire à manger à mes petits
frères et soeurs moment il était papa il
devais avoir 6 ans oui et ça mais ça
m'est déjà arrivé de d'ouvrir les
placards de retrouver juste à vieux
paquet de riz c'est incroyable et ils le
vivent
je vivais comment votre frère votre nom
puisque vous avez plus de bondues toute
nouvelle lame non du tout on a eu les
dernières nouvelles qu'on a eue c'était
il ya quatre semaines par une
journaliste de quoi elles ans pour qui
nous a envoyé les photos vous n'avez pas
pu vous enfuir avec va partir avec vous
non bah mon petit frère était beaucoup
trop petit et ma petite soeur elle était
c'était encore une petite fille à
l'aider croyant sa mère c'est ça et donc
léonie elle elle est complètement sous
l'emprise donc votre maman sa reprise de
rémy d'ail et comment elle est tombée
sous l'emprise de cet homme
il y en a en fait elle a cherché des
solutions pour scolariser les enfants
sur le net et elle est tombée sur son
site de l'école à la maison d'ailleurs
je tiens à dire qu'il utilise l'image de
mes enfants puisque à son avocat ça
tombe bien on va certainement parler
bientôt de l'image de mes enfants sans
sans mon autorisation bon alors mon nom
mais droit cyril deux paires ont été
énormément bafoués dans cet art ya eu
des passeports qui ont été faits contre
mon gré contre ma volonté
mes enfants seraient pas en prison si on
m'avait écouté en ce moment mes enfants
seraient rentrés les passeports arrivé
au bout pas malgré sa contre mon contre
m'en vouloir on a renouvelé les
passeports de mes enfants
savoir aussi que dans mon divorce rémy
d'ailleurs à réclamer de l'argent
du jamais vu pour le juge quand même
hein il a réclamé 30 35 mille euros dans
mon divorce
ils ont produit des faux des fausses
pistes de paye une fiche de paye ou aux
trente 30 février
moi par exemple il y en a eu des faux
ils sont malins ouais ouais ils sont
vraiment en plus c'est là la west
broadway
voilà donc face et des génies mais ils
sont quand même rémy daillet quand même
très dangereux parce que ils brassent
quoi il ya le poids il a vu l'état de
ses comptes en banque il ya qu'il ya des
inconnues quoi nous on les connaît pas
on ne sait pas notre top là moi ce soir
je suis quand même la peau cyril pour
faire un appel au secours quand même
avant toute chose c'est ça ça fait
depuis cinq ans ne peut nous enlever aux
enfants voilà
et puis surtout là les enfants dorment
par terre dans une prison sans matelas
je dire on aider on est des européens et
on est des français on est des européens
retraite panneaux concept de rien comme
ça oui c'est des enfants en allah et un
état c'est tout ce qui peut je le pense
aujourd'hui l'état fait ce qu'il peut
mais le problème c'est la malaisie
aujourd'hui en plus ils sont rentrés
aujourd'hui dans un couvre-feu spéciale
donc c'est très compliqué pour les
services du ministère des affaires
étrangères à votre combat aujourd'hui
c'est le retour de sanayeh et dylan en
voilà et d'avoir le regard des deux
revoilà évidemment on va bosser
voilà qui soir scolarisés qu est ce qu
on vous lit vous avez fait quelle
démarche
ben j'ai fait toutes les démarches
possibles et inimaginables j'ai fait
déjà appelé des associations jamais sans
papa qu'est ce qu'on vous dit ben on
nous dit que c'est la malaisie et que et
que voilà et puis bon qu il semble que
quand même rémy daillet comme un pas mal
de l'influent d'influencé de relations
quoi puisque mon divorce est épique
ainsi rice a été le premier juge juge me
dis ouais les enfants rendent tout de
suite c'est quoi cette histoire en gros
un mois après le juge change comme par
magie il change tout alors que mon bail
à paille on n'est pas au pénal il ya des
ya pas eu de nouveau faire donc au monde
comme des bombes des boutons ne dit pas
non vos enfants rentrent pas voilà et au
final ben ammar avec un paquet preuves
comme ça défaut tout ça mon finale entre
guillemets on gagne jamais puisque les
enfants sont parvenus j'ai pas gagné
mais bon aujourd'hui la décision de
justice qui dit que vos enfants doivent
rentrer ou pas alors j'ai une décision
de justice qui me donne la garde de mes
enfants c'est ça tous les étés un qui
n'a jamais leur hummer la nageur a été
appliquée bas remy daillet a pas envie
que mes enfants je leur raconte la
vérité avec écueil l on leur explique
surtout à sa taille parce que le petit
hack neuf ans donc on épargnera mai
mais voilà donc il n'a pas envie qu'on
fasse tomber le masque ans alors on est
le maître maître jean christophe bassons
lardy merci vous êtes avocat de rémy
d'ail et quand vous entendez toute cette
histoire vous répondez quoi parce que
c'est incroyable on a tous quand je
pense que tous les téléspectateurs qui
regardent l'émission soir c'est dit on
aimerait que ses enfants retournent chez
leur père et chez leurs grands frères
alors celui de moi quand j'entends cette
histoire si je considère un tant soit
peu les choses d'une façon un petit peu
objective extérieur jeu j'entends et je
prends la responsabilité de le dire
j'entends un tissu de mensonges
j'entends des choses qui sont à dormir
debout donc ce n'est pas parce que ce
monsieur énoncé un certain nombre de
choses il faut prendre pour argent
comptant ce qu'il dit mais il ya les
régionales et de la première des choses
c'est important qui va croire sur un
plateau télé qu'un enfant de 14 ans peut
s'enfuir et prendre un avion tout seul
un enfant de 14 ans il est remis au
personnel navigant par quelqu'un qui a
l'autorité parentale à savoir par sa
mère ça c'est la première des choses là
deux ce n'est pas un c'est la première
des choses sur la plus grosse énormité
qui a été dit et je suis pas là pour ça
encore une fois je suis là pour lancer
un véritable appel à l'aide
et pas pour essayer d' instrumentaliser
une situation de surfer sur une bague
pour faire valoir des droits qui ont
déjà étaient et bien et qui ont déjà été
demandés auprès de la justice monsieur
il a prétendu qu'ils avaient un
enlèvement international de ses enfants
interpol a été saisie les autorités
françaises ont agi en collaboration en
coopération avec les autorités
malaisiennes
ça a été classée sans suite monsieur des
poses très régulièrement des plaintes
pénales pour non représentation d'enfant
puisque il prétend que l'on ne peut pas
quand qu'on ne lui donne pas comme il le
disait hier l'instant et bien des
bêtises et je danse en commandite et
d'hébergement donc ses enfants non mais
je dois dire n'importe quoi c'est vrai
la pelletée mais je ne vous ai pas coupé
qu'en plein mais moi je vous coupe les
étés la possibilité effectivement c'est
pas possible je vous dis voir ses
enfants pendant une période qui est
prévue seulement 10 des plaintes parce
que j'ai un divorce une charge les
billets monsieur et je vais au québec de
n'importe quoi il a des droits
cette volée splendide
deux bandas devant la télévision la
justice française
[Musique]
ces éléments la justice française à
juger classée sans suite et non ceux ci
a chopé qui vous amène à l'aéroport
jusqu' à l' aéroport c'était ma mère
d'accord donc votre mère vous à
l'aéroport pour vous paraît pas possible
de toujours de malaisie sans cela de
toute façon et c'est évident oui mais
donc sa mère a bien voulu libérer enfin
n'y a pas de libération entre la
libération il n'y a pas d aberration
mais je suis pas là pour débattre de ce
que des tissus de mensonges de toutes
ces choses diffamation est jugé avec le
gourou sur l'emprise sur tout ça à la
réalité c est que l'exploit de ce
matériel est décédée deux de ses enfants
de ce monsieur
une gamine de deux ans et un bébé à
naître deux qu'il ya les enceintes de
six mois de grossesse à risque ils sont
en train de croupir au maire si ça aussi
la volonté des autorités françaises est
là pour se retrouver là mais ça pourrait
d'abord avec nous alors mais tu as
raison mais espérait le faire revenir le
chandail et les deux parties vous voulez
la même chose
oui bien sûr et tout ce qu'ils
reviennent ici non pas du tout moi je
veux pas qu'ils reviennent ici mais qui
n en voulait pas qu'ils reviennent ici
vous voulez tirer ce coopérant malaisie
vous mes enfants non il parle de
racaille est un monsieur dassier va bien
d'ici un mois si on peut prendre à
partie dans toute façon moi j'ai des
règles déontologiques qui m'empêche
d'aller un petit peu trop loin
simplement aujourd'hui faut bien
remettre les choses dans leur contexte
remy daillet neony bardet et les enfants
de vos enfants
leurs enfants étaient en situation
régulière en malaisie
compte tenu du look d'armes le
confinement là bas les administrations
étaient fermées
tous les ressortissants étrangers ont eu
le rendez-vous tout était annulé pour et
bien étendre leur visa on a eu une note
des autorités françaises de l'ambassade
de france le 13 avril qui publie un
ressortissant français
une autre leur disant à partir du 21
avril les autorités malaisiennes réclame
que vous déposiez tous des dossiers
d'extorsion de visa et voici l'adresse
mail pour demander parce que c'est
requis dans ce dossier aux autorités
françaises une lettre de soutien
c'est une formalité administrative et
consulaires la famille daguet bardet l'a
demandé et comme monsieur douillet a été
cité comme un prétendu instigateurs et
bien de l'enlèvement dans la ferme il ya
les autorités consulaires françaises à
l'état français et l'état français
réceptionné cette lettre de soutien qui
est une formalité en mal
armada d arrêt international la france
contre lui un mandat national belge ça
n'existe pas c'est un mauvais jeu l'on
transmet à des jets à des pays qui sont
hors de l'union européenne c'est un
mandat d'arrêt où on demande à un étage
sur la france et la malaisie
ça je sais oui mais ça n'empêche pas
qu'il peut être extradé les deux
rapports avec des enfants de 9 ans de
deux ans un bébé à naître et ma cliente
n'y en a aucun on a une prise d'otages
on prend en otage et mis assez été pris
en otage
alors s'il vous plaît moitié ce soit
c'est un de ces équipes nationales et
avec la chine l'ancien président chadli
fait ce soir des conditions de torture
qui sont inhumaines et dégradantes
qu'elle se jette ce soir en exclusivité
mon art message de léonie l'accompagnent
donc de remy daillet matin qui est donc
emprisonné avec son compagnon
nous avons pu contacter c'est aussi la
mère de yaël et l'ex épouse dans l'union
elle parle notamment des conditions de
détention regarder et surtout écouter on
a fait l'aveu
il ya beaucoup de bruit tout le temps et
lumière en permanence avec qui pourquoi
pas oui de cuisine et a lancé un message
pour vous yelle et coûtait rien lui dire
que tu n'es pas oublié je n'aimerais pas
les enfermer les caries mary cohr de
leclerc de reprise et une mère à l'aise
dès des enfants comme ça ceux des frères
et soeurs ce ce message ça la salle à ça
me rend dingue non mais qu'est-ce qui
vous rendrait alors les merdes qui
laisse des frères et soeurs séparés
comme ça me laisse pas d'effet merci
alors à un moment on l'emprisonnent hall
emprisonnons l'empêchent de sortir en
malaisie et puis comme c'est faux et
qu'il a démis le souhait de revenir en
france
il est revenu en scène enfin la justice
française est intervenue
voyez comme non
la paire nicole ya quand même non
présentation des enfants depuis cinq ans
sinon il ya bien deux représentations
il faut arriver on est bien là c'est
carrément charger ou pas puisque j'étais
content ici là pour un monsieur qui
aimerait bien récupérer ses enfants à
cosne d'allier quand même 14 ans donc et
qui peut parler la mer les réunit c'est
vrai les l'histoire l'histoire à l'école
curieuse la maman va en malaisie avec
ses enfants trop rigide
l'hôte ils se retrouvent elles se
retrouvent avec j'ai envie de dire ce
remy daillet voilà entre guillemets ce
goût voilà et elle veut plus voir son ex
mari l'histoire à l'école
curieusement c'est l'histoire d'un point
de vue oui bah sa cliente c'est pas ça
qui s'est passé alors qu'il s'est passé
tout près les parties ils se sont
rencontrés tous en couple les billets et
les van erp bardet d'accord ils ont
prévu tout expatrié ensemble assure elle
est partie parce que monsieur avait des
choses à faire partie avant il avait
déclaré la partie avec les médailles à
des médaillés étaient déjà sur place a
été logé dans un appartement vous
raconter la même histoire mais au bout
de trois jours ce monsieur qui a dit
qu'il ne viendrait pas non c'est faux ça
mais on a les preuves n'étaient pas dues
aux amoureux pouvait on va servir
l'épreuve allait s'entraîner sur ses
toits des maisons
non mais l'encré 1000 à l'équipe mais
vous déviez lorsque vous lirez
je regardais pourquoi j'ai porté plainte
parce qu'on n'avait aucune nouvelle
j'ai fait venir un père paul écoutez
bien monsieur écoutez le parce que c'est
dans les actes de justice
j'ai porté plainte sur interpol parce
qu'en fait j'avais aucune nouvelle sur
ce qu'il me demandait ce qui se passait
là bas
concrètement je me suis dit mais qu'est
ce qui se passe là-bas donc j'ai
contacté interpol j'ai dit mais à mais
qu'est ce qui se passe là bas ma femme
est drôle ou iphone mais moi j'ai
embrassé ma femme à l'aéroport voyez
quitter mes enfants à l'aéroport j'ai
dit on se revoit dans un mois voilà elle
a réservé un appartement plaît elle
avait réservé un appartement
j'arrête m excusez moi mais votre
discours il est quand même terriblement
ambigu c'est selon lui on a on à la
détresse d'un père qui veut récupérer
ses enfants et vous vous nous sortez des
arguties sur le visage et je viens mais
laissez moi finir vous nous sortez des
trucs sur le visa qui aurait expiré qui
est en règle ou pas mais ce rapport
c'est pourquoi la détention il faut
qu'ils sortent de cette cellule immonde
d'accord on est dominants mais il faut
ensuite que les enfants reviennent parce
que vous voulez quoi être complaisant
dire vous ne voulez pas d'élire le
jugement de divorce nom vient du monde
dit mardi très forts soupçons de
manipulation de madame de la mère des
enfants par rémy daillet qui est un
manipulateur maintenant vous le savez
très bien
trouvent leur père ce qu'on fait là en
plus c'est que vous êtes en train
dénoncer des choses qui ont déjà été
jugés ce monsieur ça fait cinq ans qu'il
a tout tenté au niveau de la justice
française la justice française lui a
donné tort non c'est fou et sera donné
le droit de visite l'été les marchés où
les pneus ne veut pas renvoyer ne veut
pas renvoyer lors sinon je n'aurais pas
céder quasi sans suivant il faut pas été
classée sans suite ah bon ah ouais
montrer leur ils ont été classés ça ne
passera pas vous voulez qu'on appelle la
procureure du génialissime d'aller vous
allez passer de travail à faire vivez
vous
juste vous pouvez comprendre que des
enfants ont besoin de voir leur père ou
handicapées a besoin de marquer
scherwiller a besoin de vérité c'est
très bien moi ce que je dis ou jamais
dire oui c'est que effectivement on est
là sur deux débats qui sont parallèles
et l'urgence et cie qui se devrait
émouvoir
aujourd'hui les français et la
communauté internationale ce sont les
conditions géodésie touristes de la
toiture de gamme
il a tellement cracher sur la france en
disant qu'on était une dictature mais
oui avec les geôles malaisie bien sûr
quelques pages sur la france est là qu
on peut les [ __ ] en taule mais bien
parce que la pomme a considéré qu est
doré médaillés mais ne confondez pas un
sombre tableau n'est pas tout en tout
cas ce qu'on aimerait c'est qu'il puisse
revenir en france
oui l'inra pour les enfants un appel
solennel
hormis tout ça maintenant faut calmer le
débat à un appel au roi de malaisie
voilà je vous aime mais je vous implore
majesté votre clémence pour mes enfants
renvoyer les dans leur pays
voilà où ils seront voilà le temps que
que les choses se clarifient avec tout
avec toutes ces histoires voilà c'est un
grand pays la malaisie
soyez miséricordieux voilà d'ailleurs si
ça si ça se fait si on l'a on envisage
une action donc avec yaël 1
on a créé une cagnotte litchi alors
libéré mes frères et soeurs c'est elle
qui l'a créée on envisage d'aller en
malaisie avec qui elle cherchait son
frère et sa soeur à la prison est là-bas
mexique les gens peuvent nous aider
voilà aujourd'hui parce que il faut des
moyens pour aller là bas et nous on vit
chichement dans le gers
donc voila merci mais quelque chose a
ajouté j'ai deux choses a ajouté la
première c'est que 100 m du sur le feu
sur un débat qui pour moi est secondaire
au moins dans la temporalité parce que
l'urgence et d'urgence humanitaire
aujourd'hui pour cette famille on peut
vraiment traité de tous les noms
prêter tous les comportements du monde à
rémy daillet on en a le chacun a le
droit de penser ce qu'il veut
il est présumé innocent via le secret
d'instruction qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
moi j'ai aucun élément concret objectifs
de sa participation à quelque titre que
ce soit à l'enlèvement de cette petite
fille qui a été retrouvé en deux jours
ou en 3 jours 3 jours c'est laisser le
temps en fait depuis lequel ces enfants
sont détenus dans des conditions qu'on
le souhaite à personne dans des
conditions qui sont inhumaines et
dégradantes
c'est l'urgence c'est que ces enfants de
cette famille puisse sortir de cette
détention etc et dans le petit chien des
pâtes et qui veut faire à manger à ses
frères et sa danse danse assez ce qu'ils
racontent
et c'était pas prévu de le dire mais là
je crois que franchement cette espèce de
de bronca et puis deux tendances
s'affrontent trois en comptant ce que
disent ces personnes m'oblige à le dire
le syndrome d'aliénation parentale la
manipulation depuis cinq ans par son
père en france on peut l'imaginer manif
ils parlent tous les jours devant les
juges aux affaires familiales jamais été
condamné pour violences conjugales oui
oui j'ai testé